-Hello, everyone and welcome
back to the attic.
I want to start by addressing
something
because there have been some
nasty rumors online.
The books on my side table are
real books, with real titles,
by real authors,
and I'm not switching in
fake ones
over the course of the show.
I would never, what, ask
the art department at our show
to make phony book covers
for nonexistent
"Thorn Bird" sequels
and have them sent here
in the mail for a bit that
all of, I want to say,
eight people tops
would even enjoy?
I mean, that would be
a colossal waste of time.
And I also want to assure you
that if it was a bit,
which it's not,
I would stop it immediately
before it dragged out
and became unsatisfying.
Speaking of unsatisfying --
boom, another perfect segue --
the president is declaring
victory on coronavirus
even as a whistleblower
offered damning testimony today
on the Trump administration's
disastrous response.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Today the House heard damning
testimony from Dr. Rick Bright,
a whistleblower who was
punished for questioning
the president's aggressive
advertising
of the unproven anti-malaria
drug hydroxychloroquine
as a treatment for coronavirus.
Do you remember
hydroxychloroquine,
the Furby of medical fads
for like a month?
Hydroxychloroquine was hotter
than CBD oil,
and it turns out
works just as well.
Bright made clear today that his
caution on hydroxychloroquine
was part of the reason
he was pushed out.
-I believe part of
the removal process for me
was initiated because
of a pushback
that I gave when they asked me
to put in place
an expanded access protocol
that would make
chloroquine more freely
available to Americans
that were not under the close
supervision of a physician
and may not even be confirmed
to be infected
with the coronavirus.
-That's right,
they wanted to give it out to
people who might not even
have had coronavirus.
I wouldn't be surprised if Trump
had personally submitted
a request to travel
around the country
in a windowless white van
offering loose bags
of chloroquine to kids.
[ As Trump ] "You guys want to
ride the quine?
I'll meet you out back
behind the bleachers.
This is a tiny bag of drugs."
Bright, a vaccine expert
who led a biodefense agency
in the health department,
had a stark assessment
of just how badly
the Trump administration
had failed
in its response to
the coronavirus outbreak.
-I believe we could have
done better.
I believe there are
critical steps
that we did not take in time.
Those alarms were not
responded to with action.
-Okay, side note here,
but that is
what I want a doctor
to sound like --
calm, reasonable,
doesn't engage in hyperbole,
gives it to you straight.
Trump, of course, prefers
that his doctors sound like
roadies for Metallica.
"Hey, man, I looked
at your CAT scan.
Looks like you got what
we call upside-down disease.
Anyway, you want to
ride the quine?"
Although I have to say,
probably even more shocking
than that comment
was this moment
when Bright relayed
a conversation he had
about our shortage
of respirator masks.
-Congressman, I'll never
forget the e-mails I received
from Mike Bowen indicating
that our mask supply
or N-95 respirator supply
was completely decimated,
and he said,
"We're in deep [bleep]."
-Wow, you know it's bad when
someone as soft-spoken
as this guy drops a curse word
on live television.
It's like FaceTiming
with your grandma
and asking her how
her knitting is going.
"Oh, you know, I just do it
to pass the time
while I'm baking cookies.
These mother [bleep]
are taking forever."
Bright had a damning and truly
harrowing assessment
of where we are as a nation
on everything
from vaccines to testing.
And he warned that
if we don't put together
a national strategy now,
things could be very bleak
come the fall.
-Without better planning,
2020 could be the darkest
winter in modern history.
The truth must be based
on science.
We have the world's greatest
scientists, let us lead.
Let us speak without fear
of retribution.
There are things we must
do immediately.
We must increase the public
education about the basics --
washing hands,
social distancing,
appropriate face covering.
-Of course, as he was
watching that,
there was a good chance Trump
was sneezing into his hands,
surrounded by reporters
and wearing a face mask
over his eyes.
"If I can't see you,
I can't give you the corona."
Instead of listening to Bright
and taking his warnings
seriously,
Trump was on Fox News
this morning,
bragging about the one thing
he always brags about,
the China travel ban
he imposed in late January.
The "New York Times"
reported last month
that 430,000 people have
traveled from China to the U.S.
since coronavirus surfaced.
But that hasn't stopped Trump
from saying stuff like this...
-In January, I put -- and I
was criticized by everybody,
including Dr. Fauci,
I put in a wall.
We put in a very strong wall.
-There's a good chance Trump
thinks they built a literal wall
between the U.S. and China.
"We built a wall in the Pacific
keeping out immigrants,
manatees, sharks, and whales.
Unfortunately, we've had
less trouble, less success,
I should say,
stopping dolphins,
what with all the tricks they've
learned at SeaWorld.
SeaWorld, of course,
a water park
that thrived under Obama.
So, if we're pointing
fingers..."
The frustrating thing
about listening
to Dr. Bright's testimony
is that everything
he's talking about is possible,
as we've seen
from other countries.
Throughout this crisis,
Americans have watched
as countries across the world,
from Germany to Australia,
New Zealand to Taiwan
successfully contained
and suppressed their coronavirus
outbreaks
and began to safely and slowly
reopen their economies.
Meanwhile, here in the U.S.,
things are so bad, we have
senators showing up to hearings
like outlaw highwaymen,
drinking alone
in the corner of a salon.
Tim Kaine,
what happened to you?
You went from vice presidential
nominee to divorced dad
who forgot it was Halloween.
Although, I honestly do wish
this Tim Kaine
had been Hillary Clinton's
running mate.
Instead of debating Mike Pence,
he would have challenged him
to a dual.
"Hey, Mike Pence, how about you
Pokémon -- go to hell."
Pow-pow!
Insanely good mime work today.
You guys remember the quine?
Although, I will give him credit
for at least wearing a mask,
unlike some of his
Republican colleagues,
who have decided to
turn mask wearing,
a proven technique
for eliminating transmission
of respiratory illnesses,
into yet another
dumb culture war issue.
Like Louisiana Senator
John Kennedy,
who said this bizarre thing
on Fox News.
-I don't want to have to wear
a face mask in the shower.
-Okay, so don't.
I think are you're safe.
I doubt anybody would want to be
within six feet of you
when you're naked and wet.
No one's telling you to wear
a face mask in the shower.
Although, based on
voice alone,
if anyone sounds like
they should be wearing
a Tim Kaine-style bandana,
it's this Douche of Hazzard.
Seriously, can we just
make stuff up
and then
get angry about it now?
"And another thing, I don't want
these crazy libs telling me
to wear socks on my hands
and a bucket on my chin.
I mean, I'll do it
for public health,
but I won't be
happy about it."
You only need to wear a mask
when you're out,
around other people, or when you
can't socially distance.
I mean, where are you taking
your showers?
Are you secretly
a Starship Trooper?
Underrated film. If you want to
catch up on that one,
this is a good time to do it.
Mask wearing
is a simple technique
that's been proven to
reduce the transmission
of respiratory illnesses,
and it's been adopted widely
in countries that have
successfully contained or
suppressed their outbreaks.
Like South Korea, which had
their first confirmed case
on the same day we had ours.
South Korea successfully
contained their outbreak
early on, and they did it with
massive nationwide testing.
It wasn't just widespread,
it was early.
At the beginning of March,
for example,
when it was reported that fewer
than 500 people had been tested
here in the U.S.,
in South Korea, they already had
drive-thru setups, where
anyone could get tested safely
without leaving their car
and receive their results back
in a few days.
I know if you told Trump
other countries were beating us
on tests, he wouldn't care,
but if you told him
other countries were beating
were beating us on drive-thrus,
we would have had
this problem solved ASAP.
"Today I'm invoking
the Defense Protection Act
to immediately ramp up
our nation's supply
of masks, Frosty, Whoppers,
apple pies.
And I'm proud to announce today
that thanks to the efforts
of our search,
the McRib is back.
The one curve you don't want
to flatten."
And by the way, that doesn't
mean coronavirus
just disappeared forever
in South Korea.
In fact, they just had to
reimpose some lockdown measures
after a resurgence of cases.
But that tells us two things --
one, you can't just
reopen the economy
without expecting that
outbreaks reoccur.
And two, you need an aggressive
regime of testing,
tracing, and isolation.
If we had that here,
everyone would feel
much more comfortable
knowing that if we went
back to work,
and there was another outbreak,
we'd detect it early
and respond quickly.
Instead, we have senators
dressing like
NPCs in "Red Dead Redemption,"
and others complaining
that mask wearing
is ruining their nightly
bubble bath.
"I'd like to sit in my tub.
And I'd blow bubbles,
but I can't do that
'cause I have to wear a mask to
avoid spreading coronavirus
to my ducky."
Now, South Korea set up
their drive-thru testing
in February.
By mid-March, Trump
announced his own plan
to expand drive-thru testing,
but he decided to rely on
private companies instead,
and did his usual schtick
where he calls them up
one by one to talk about
how great they are.
-We've been in discussions
with pharmacies and retailers
to make drive-thru tests
available
in the critical locations
identified by public
health professionals.
One of them is Doug McMillon
from Walmart.
And I'd like to have Doug,
if you would, say a few words.
And, Richard, if you could
come up, please.
Richard, please.
Walgreens.
Brian Cornell.
Target.
Is Tom here?
Tom Polen?
And Matt Sauce, please,
of Roche.
David Pierre of Signify --
Signify Health.
Adam Schechter, who's really
been of tremendous help,
LabCorp, please.
Thomas Moriarty, CVS.
We all know CVS.
-"Duane and Reade
from Duane Reade.
Thank you both for making it.
Matthias Mickelberry,
CEO of M&Ms, great work.
Long John Silver,
right over there.
We all know Long John.
Thar he blows, right over there.
The Taco Bell chihuahua.
What's that?
He's not in his box?
Well, you have to think
outside the box.
Or just find him.
Why? Because yo quiero him
to be here.
The Noid? Where's the Noid?
Right over there.
It would break my heart
if I avoided the Noid.
I think this -- has this bit
gone on long enough?
Oh, Little Ceasars pizza.
You know, a lot of people --
a lot of people think
he's saying, 'pizza, pizza,'
but not me.
I know it's 'Pizza. Pizza.'
Coppertone baby.
Where's the Coppertone --
Where is she?
She can't get up
because the dog has her
swimsuit in its mouth?
Is it the Taco Bell dog?
Well, why don't you check?"
So, that was mid-March.
I think that was the right
amount of time to do that.
Already far too late to begin
scaling up tests.
Again, it came after a testing
debacle at the CDC
that significantly slowed
our response, but still,
it was a promising initiative,
if it could get up
and run in quickly.
Instead, a month after
Trump's announcement,
"Business Insider"
found only eight sites
were operating among
three of the companies,
the fourth Walgreens wasn't able
to open the first batch
of its promised 15 locations
until April 17th,
Target opened only one site,
and appears to have dropped out
of the effort.
And if you go to CVS,
they just decided to stop having
employees altogether.
Actually, all CVSs are
technically drive-thrus
and that you could literally
drive through one
and there would be no one
there to stop you.
This is why we need
an actual functioning
centralized federal government
that listens to scientists
instead of just relying on
private companies
to do things that don't benefit
their investors
or their bottom lines.
Republicans love to hollow out
the government
and outsource everything
to big business
and then complain
the government is incompetent
and should be run like
a business.
That's their scam --
make government incompetent,
then use that incompetence as
proof that government is bad.
They're like a husband who
cheats on his wife and says,
"See, this is proof
we need an open marriage."
In fact, Republicans
are now arguing
that nonpartisan public health
officials,
like Dr. Anthony Fauci,
the nation's leading
infectious disease expert,
shouldn't be allowed
to make decisions about
the government's
coronavirus response.
-I think
the one-size-fits-all,
that we're going to have
a national strategy
and nobody's going to go
to school is kind of ridiculous.
So I think we ought to have
a little bit of humility
in our belief that we know
what's best for the economy.
And as much as I respect you,
Dr. Fauci,
I don't think
you're the end-all.
I don't think you're
the one person
that gets to make a decision.
-No one said he was.
He wasn't even the one person
at that hearing.
There were four top public
health officials who testified,
including FDA Commissioner
Stephen Hahn,
who Skyped in, I'm guessing,
from the finale of "Lost"?
"I am going to try to keep
my answers brief,
as I may be a ghost."
Also, as Fauci pointed out,
all he does
is offer advice
as a doctor and public official.
He often corrects himself
or amends his judgments
based on new information,
and he doesn't make
any policy decisions.
Yet they're acting like he's
somehow a puppet master
controlling an otherwise
powerless Trump.
Trump's the president.
He's supposed to be the one who
makes all the actual decisions.
And yet, in their all-consuming
attempts to cover
for the president's failures,
they've been casting about
for someone else to blame,
and they've apparently landed
on Fauci.
If you don't like the decisions
Trump makes,
then take it up with him.
Of course, in this case,
it's just easier
to pretend Anthony Fauci is
president, not Donald Trump,
because then you'd
have to acknowledge
that the horrific death toll
and the cratering economy
have unfolded under
Trump's watch.
Instead, Fox News would rather
concoct an elaborate fantasy
where Fauci is making
all the calls,
while he has Trump tied
to a chair in a closet
with duct tape over his mouth.
"Fauci! Let me go!
I see you, Fauci.
You can't hide from me."
As we've seen
from other countries,
it's possible to have
an aggressive regime of testing,
contact tracing, and social
distancing to keep people safe,
while also making sure
they keep their paychecks
and health insurance.
But Trump and his allies have
no interest in any of that.
They'd rather wish the virus
away and send working people
back into the economy
like cannon fodder
while they do their shows
in safe isolation.
They don't care if otherwise
mild-mannered scientists
are warning us that we're in...
-Deep [bleep].
See, real book.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Please continue to give
to City Harvest.
Every day more New Yorkers
need their help
putting food on the tables.
If you're watching this
online,
you can hit
the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.